hi there steve kaufman here
uh to talk about language learning and
uh of course if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe
so today i want to talk about something
that we hear quite a lot
uh when people talk about language
learning and that is you know use it or
lose it
and people are afraid sometimes that if
they
you know
for whatever reason have to discontinue
learning a language or if they
go away from a language for a long
period of time somehow they will lose
their ability in that language
um basically i don't
subscribe to this use it or lose a
theory so i'm going to approach this
from various points of view
first of all
uh
many languages i learned basically
without speaking for the longest time
so to me the using
of a language includes listening and
reading because that still is using the
language you're using the language to
understand things you're listening to it
you're engaging with words in the
language so
very much listening and reading or
writing
obviously are forms of using the
language just as speaking is a form of
using the language and though people
often ask me how do you refresh in a
language that you learned previously
well i get busy listening and reading
so that's point number one so the the
using in use it or lose it has to
include listening and reading things
that you can do whenever you want and in
fact you can go back to
some of the lessons for example and so
let me move on to the point number two
point number two is when it comes to
speaking in the language you are going
to get rusty if you don't use it however
you can very quickly recover
you know the level that you had before
so for example i'll give you some
examples
i was in bratislava
um
you know whatever it was i'm like a year
and a half ago
and in the lead up to bratislava
i put a lot of effort into learning
slovak slovakia
and it kind of pushed my ukrainian out
of the way so that when i was in
bratislava at the meeting i i would meet
this ukrainian person i essentially
couldn't say anything in ukrainian even
though i had accumulated a very large
vocabulary
and had read books and listened to audio
books on ukrainian history and so on and
so on i couldn't say anything but from
bratislava
i went to levi ukraine where i had
arranged these sessions
with this excellent teacher solomia who
works at the ukrainian language and
culture
center or school in la vie which i
highly recommend
and from the very first session once we
had three hours of
you know the ability to talk my
ukrainian came back i was no longer
trying to you know work on slovakia and
so forth and so on so the point is that
you get rusty initially but you very
quickly can reactivate what you had
especially if you prepare yourself for
the reactivation by doing a lot of
listening and reading so that's the
second point so point number one is that
listening and reading is part of using
point number two is that your speaking
will suffer a bit but it'll activate
very quickly and it'll activate more
quickly if you spend that effort
at reactivating it by using it in your
listing and reading another example i
often use is
if i have to i have sometimes been asked
to appear on say mandarin chinese
television in vancouver
and to prepare for that i will listen
and read a lot in chinese i won't speak
much but then when i get to the
television studio i have kind of
refreshed it so listening and reading is
a great way to refi refresh your
language okay the third point is
not only do i
not notice
any real slippage in the language if i
go away from it
but in some cases it actually improves
and i'll give you a number of examples
uh right now
because we had visitors here for a week
i wasn't able to do any arabic at all
but then when i start up my arabic
listening again i find that i hear it
better in other words there was a period
there a week of call it benign neglect
and it's good for the brain
sometimes you're pushing too hard and
the brain is resisting
because it's it's kind of you're forcing
sort of this new language
and whereas if you leave it alone for a
while i find that there's almost like a
gestation it's not like you put a
you put a loaf of bread in the oven to
bake like it seems to get better and so
i noticed that with my uh arabic i hear
it more clearly now having left it for a
week
but that's you know on on the basis that
i've worked you know every day i've been
listening to arabic and then i leave it
for a week and i come back to it and i
hear it better and i have noticed this
before for example i mentioned that
for example i was listening to these
chinese stories cds that i have at home
and then i went through a period of very
intensive swedish study because i was
going to be going to sweden so i'm
listening to herman lindqvist
you know history of sweden and a whole
bunch of stuff reading in swedish that i
was in sweden
and then i come back and i listen to
those chinese cds i understand them
better
so
whether that's because
learning this other language
made my brain more
observant of the language
or because the the language simply just
stated in the background but this period
of benign neglect actually made my
chinese better
so i am never afraid that it for example
right now my greek i couldn't probably
say anything in greek but
if i
however i do follow some people in
uh greek on twitter and when i read
those little uh tweets i'm very happy
that i'm able to read them there's
missing words but i can read greek if i
went back to listening and reading in
greek
i would very quickly come back to where
i was so i'm not at all concerned and i
don't think people should be concerned
uh if they have to leave the language
for a short while or if they want to go
and learn another language and then come
back to that first language again this
use it and or lose it really doesn't
apply although there are sort of initial
an initial period of rustiness and that
initial period of rustiness
will be you know how long that period of
rustiness is will depend on how well you
know that language how much time you had
previously put into that language i mean
those languages that i speak very well i
don't lose them at all but those
languages that i speak less well there
is this rustiness and this requirement
for a sort of a reactivation but i don't
lose anything
uh one other thing final thing someone
asked me to talk about sentence mining
as a learning technique and i don't know
much about it i haven't done it i'd be
interested in comments from others
uh my
feeling always has been that the
fundamental structures of the language
are contained in phrases
and so that if if i tend to focus on
phrases that capture the main structures
of the language and also vocabulary
words
i have tended to find
that sentences are too
unique each sentence is unique phrases
repeat words repeat sentences are unique
so
you know when i study
uh on link in sentence mode which at the
present time exists in the web version
in other words on on the internet
whether you're using your
ipad or or your computer
and it exists in the sort of beta
version of the app for the ios it will
soon be available for everyone but so as
i look at these individual sentences as
i'm learning my arabic sentence by
sentence there's too much specific stuff
in each sentence might be the name of a
person it might be a specific situation
that's specific to whatever that
sentence is describing so my preference
when i'm working at link is to save
phrases phrases that capture some of the
structures the patterns that i find
useful so that's my take on it
i'd be interested to hear from others uh
you know when we're learning do we learn
just words
do we learn phrases phrases and words
phrases words sentences what is it that
you focus on learning so
there you have it my take on use it
or lose it which i think is a
not a meaningful
motto
and again i look forward to your
comments
[Music]
you